>> Sean: we've been wandering down the the
by-roads of HTML, XML, SGML all
sorts of MLs and various non-MLs
And last time, I think, we spoke some
people had wandered off to the pub and
sorted everything out over a point so
what happened about that then -- what
happened next?
>> DFB: well after about 18 months the draft
XML specification was published and
everybody agreed: "Great job! Didn't we
learn a lot from the decisions in HTML
that caused so much difficulty and, of course,
the major thing --
not by any means the only one -- but a big major thing,
was that you must not omit your end-tags in XML. They
will be there. That being said, of course,
a lot of browsers still have to be
tolerant about it. Some people, y'know,
maybe -- I dunno -- Dreamweaver, or something,
might produce a very, very good XML-compliant
Web page but a lot of people
still hand-code. A lot of people, particularly with
paragraphs, go straight <p> <p> <p> <p> and
don't see the need to close off the paragraphs.
You've got to be a bit tolerant but nevertheless
the idea was you do not omit your end-tags
and there were about seven or eight
other, rather more technical, things had
to be cleaned up from SGML but it made a
lot of difference to people implementing that
they were cleaned up. One
of the first ones I'm aware of -- because I
tend to forget it -- is that in SGML,
because it was the days of punch cards,
upper case and lower case were treated as
the same. So if you called it <PARA> in
capitals it was the same
as <para> in lower case. Or even you could
have capital 'P' little 'a' capital 'R' little 'a'
again and that
was the same as <para> ! That had to be
cleaned up. So what this made possible
was for the browser implementers they loved
it, because it meant that if all the end
tags were there you could do a brackets
matching operation, essentially, a bit like in a
compiler where you match open curly brace [{] with
close curly brace [}]. You could tick everything
off and you could
say "That is a tree, I may not understand
what all the tags mean but, boy, they match
all right". Now that's very useful to know
about so what it also meant was that
there was a clean target for front-end
software to aim at. The idea is that your
Dreamweaver(s), or whatever,
probably still aren't totally compliant, I don't
know, but they could say "We will try and produce really
good, nice, XML".  Yeah, XML-notated
Web page stuff [XHTML]. So what this really means
is that a diagram that we had in the
previous video can now be extended. You
will recall that I described SGML as
being the enabling technology, the
foundations of the building in a way, and
we built these applications on top of
them.  I did a memo. I  referred to the DoD's
CALS I referred to the Text Encoding
Initiative and I referred to HTML and
saying,  y'know, sad  it had the ML at the
end [of the acronym] -- it caused so much
misunderstanding. But anyway let's just extend this a bit
more now, over to the right, and let's just say
that what the XML committee did was to
enable, as it were, inside this SGML
universe, as a proper subset, like that, and
that one is labelled
XML and I've tried to draw it wholly
within the SGML boundary to emphasize
that, yes, it really is a genuine subset.
The theologians will say "Ah! yes but it's a
subset of the extended
SGML that included several options that
Charles [Goldfarb] specified way back
and you had to have those in order for
it to work".  But nevertheless, yes, it is in
spirit a proper subset and that meant
you could generate on top of that new
tagsets, or cleaned up versions of existing ones.
So, one of the first things they did,
of course, was to clean up HTML and
its spec. into XML format. Now remember
XML is a subset of SGML because they're the same
things -- they're meta-syntaxes -- built now on
top of XML notation is XHTML cleaned up
HTML, all tags matching, defined, wonderful.
And of course several other people -- tens
of thousands of other people now -- have
been able to build their own tagsets on
top of XML technology. Just to take one
that's very familiar to me and to some of my academic
colleagues, for mathematics mark up.
Again one wishes thay hadn't put the 'ML' on the end
but they did: MathML
Ah! here's a good one
Adobe know what they're doing. You don't put 'ML'
on the end of things unless it's a meta-language, perhaps.
They took their
PDF technology and they made it so that it
could be expressed in XML tagset form. And that
of course is called Scalable Vector
Graphics, SVG, and I'll put the dots here
to show that there are now literally, I
would guess, thousands, if not tens of
thousands. Remember all of these the way
you refer to them is you say "SVG is
an *application* of XML"
>> Sean: Can we just be absolutely clear then,
just to throw this in one more time:
What was the big problem with putting a 'L'
on the end of these?"
>> DFB: Because unfortunately the two enabling
technologies end with 'ML'. And the in-crowd
sort of says: "We know it says 'markup language' it's
actually 'markup mete-language'" But of course if you
start using it for something that is a
fixed tagset -- not a tagset
technology -- the punctuation rules so to speak --
then people start saying things like: "Oh! they're just
y' know "HTML is a subset of SGML". No! it's not a
subset of SGML it's an application, you see.
And people start to make
those mistakes, between 'applications
and 'subsets' motivated by the fact that they
all end in "ML" so thay all must mean the same
sort of thing -- and they don't!  So, peace
broke out.  I think we should say that
alongside all of this, in the
mid 1990s and equally important. It wasn't just getting XML
sorted out and thereby being able to do
HTML as XHTML, properly. It was also
the fact, I think, in that era,  Tim Berners-Lee
moved from CERN. He moved to MIT
and all credit to him. Exactly the right
thing.  I think MIT made him an offer to
host basically a sort of academic-like
institution concerned entirely with setting
standards for the Web
and being vendor-neutral in everything
it did. And as I say,  all credit to Tim. He
could have made millions out of the Web -- there's no
question. But he opted to say: "No I would
sooner make a smaller amount of money and
be respected and to have mine be the
standard way of doing things. So in a way
the vendors can meet on vendor-neutral
territory - still have shouting matches,
still have bust-ups - but its all under
the aegis of the W3C, the World
Wide Web Consortium, which is in charge
of all this.  I've never actually been to one of their
meetings but I've talked to one or two people
who've been there and I said: "How do you cope
with the fact that people still get
subsets and applications confused? Is XHTML a cut-down
version of XML ?  No! no! no! no!  "
And one said: " I'm weary, I'm going bald,
I've got a grey beard,  All we try
and ensure is it everything we say on
our Web site is absolutely accurate and
correct. But to try and get everybody in
the whole world to understand and to get it right?
Life's too short ! "